I'm back with Kasich from Lockett again
and this time we're going to be
discussing the challenges of measuring
things
so Kasich when you were measuring
different metrics what sort of barriers
or obstacles did you encounter well user
retention rate was one of the most
difficult thing to measure for us
Explorer especially because a lot of
users actually install that application
never used it but because it was there
on the lock screen we miscalculated them
as always like using users or like we
calculated their retention rates to be
very positive and like very supportive
but in reality they were not they
totally forgot about our application
they did not even know that our
application existed over there it
because it was very native and that's
how it was so that was very difficult
for us to measure we had a very unique
way of measuring the user retention
rates we considered their user
engagement as well as we considered we
had a few set of metrics which they had
to hit every single day in order to find
in order to make sure that they are
using the app consistently so that was
one challenging part and what do you
think will be most important for the
company moving forward in terms of
metrics and measurement
well first drop off between d7 to day 14
is one of the most important metric and
then number of invites each user is
sending and the number of people who are
positively responding for those invites
as well as number their current their
respective retention rates and then how
it is to how the total of this that the
chain reaction is working for example if
we buy users or someone from Facebook or
if we buy users from different sources
or quaters so we want to measure this
complete chain as to how many how much
viral coefficient it is adding and stuff
like that so that's one of the most
important things so tell me a little bit
about how you guys go about measuring
things and how did the product inform
what you measured and the metrics that
you chose that you thought were
important to track as a company all
right so we are mainly measured metrics
around two broad areas one is your user
retention rate and use
engagement rate so user retention means
like day 1 retention days I mean
retention and day 14 retention and as we
had a lock screen we are all the time on
the screen and it is really difficult to
find whether he's using it or no and he
just forgot about the application after
installing because it is right on the
lock screen so user engagement is also
very important metric where we measure
like how many times he is liking an
image how many times he is sending an
image to his friends or like easy
receiving images all these things so in
the beginning we actually thought day 1
retention rate was very important for us
but over a period of time we realize
that it's not day 1 retention rate it's
a drop off from day 7 to day 14 which
was highly important because day 1
retention rate actually was the
retention rate provided by users who did
not who might not have had friends and
screen pop but day 7 and day 14
retention rates were mostly around
people who already had friends in screen
power so they were the people who
actually sent a lot of invites they were
the people who sent a lot of messages as
well as images to their friends so
measuring those were highly critical for
us